You take one monopoly? Yeah,
I mean what did you give him?
Waterworks that ripped man.
Oh, grow cash. We board wants
the reference here. Go for it.
Kind of minority group.
My name is Kieran.
I am a senior banker.
The reason why I do what I do is to help
individuals with financial literacy.
You're absolutely.
My name is Amos and I'm a student,
a social media influencer
and a Christian apologist.
Wow, that's amazing. My
name is Michael Chang.
I am a founder,
CEO of 11 recruiting.
I love finding people jobs and
creating dreams. Did a few roles for,
oh my goodness, this is no
Steve. My name is Josh Jackson.
I'm a video editor. It's
good. I love editing videos,
but doing it since I was 14 years old,
we're walking. We're just leaving.
That was pretty cool.
Goes
all right. It's 40 bucks. It's 40
bucks. You don't have a house yet,
so I didn't want the house. It's just
want to be a buck. He's window me.
I'm just trying to struggle out.
Struggling out here.
Okay, so how much would you chop off
a Lynn for? Like how much of a limb?
How about a foot? No, no,
that was [inaudible] fee and it will
be like a whole arm or the left nipple.
What? Not a less dominant
arm. Maybe a billion dollars.
I'd probably wouldn't, you
wouldn't owe any price? Yeah. Yeah.
If you think about a body
part and how priceless it is,
think about how much more precious
your life is like your soul.
Anyways,
I think I have to go to jail.
Are you going to jail dude? Dude,
you're incarcerated.
I be
answer this question or pay a hundred
to the bank. How much do you make?
I make 55 a year.
I think I made 24 k this past year.
May I am a student right now,
so I'm technically, um, yeah,
I, I'm a business owner, so
technically nothing. Um, uh,
but last year my w two was
$350,000. Okay. Can you talk me,
is it too old to be a dumpster?
Let me get your Baltic Gavin and
then you can have this. Yeah, right.
This is a loss for me,
but I'll hook it up and I'll help you.
So now you've got a double
take. I'm looking monopoly. Hey,
don't you got to get assessed for his
decision? I am buying six houses. Oh,
why did you don't worry. You pass
go. You just give me your money.
I want to get my money, man. I'll
help you out once you get lower.
I told Mike the same thing.
Or are you playing to win now?
I'll just plan to be here.
The $250.
I would pay my rent. I actually
have my niece coming to visit me.
I actually thought about this.
I was looking to donate it and it'll be
a great time to take her around and let
her do things that she would like to do.
I probably would get some groceries.
Seriously.
Um,
are you satisfied with the amount of
money you have right now at this point?
Right now I'm pretty satisfied because
I'm pretty big on the whole like
minimalist movement. Like I
don't even have a couch or
nothing. I won't be busily.
Really depends on the mindset.
Right?
You want all this stuff or are
you kind of just like, I'm,
I'm cool with sitting on the floor and
my crew was giving away Baltic avenue.
They ain't gonna let him
live that down are, you know,
I think that's going to cost the game.
Yeah. Seriously. No, no, we'll be okay.
He's the only person with
a monopoly right now.
I felt bad because he was in jail,
but we'll be okay. I'll go to jail.
Do you want to trade?
What was the most financial lead
desperate time of your life?
How did you deal with it?
I'll go first. Uh, 2004 parents moved out.
So I basically got rid of,
uh, the place I was living at.
I literally ate TV dinners and microwave
food for like a whole year and a half.
I was actually 27 at that time.
Did you feel,
because you were such an like
a low financial like area,
did that give you like a dry Oh
fuck to like make a lot of money?
It's because I had to go through that
struggle. My emotional support was,
was limited. I saw was on the other
side. It was just the really good thing.
I knew I couldn't be successful.
I knew I was going to be great at what
I'm doing. I just had to get through this.
I guess the most financially a difficult
time in my life was a pretty recently
actually.
I was at a pretty constant freelance Gig,
like a thing where they would just
call me every week. It'd be like, Hey,
can you come in these days?
And one day they just stopped calling
so now I have to find something that's
more like consistent.
Mine's was similar to Mike.
I was 22 I just was trying
to be a full time student,
full time work and then my grandmother
told me that my little brothers had to
come live with me and I was already making
it on $100 a month with groceries and
I had to come to the conclusion
that I couldn't play hero,
that I had to let my
grandmother know that, wow,
I thank you for raising them and continue
that. I need you to finish it for me.
It's better financially for me to take
care of myself to the bring anybody else
with my sugar. It's awesome.
How's for standing for herself?
Thank you.
The imagery that I always say with that,
you know on the airplanes when they tell
you always put on your gas mask before
you help others. Yeah. Oxygen
Mask you always put on their
gas masks.
I wouldn't be good.
I guess for me it would be my childhood
because I grew up super poor and like a
lot of nights with no food and you know
going to sleep hungry and that's why I
don't really idolize money or,
but rather I try to make friends and
try to hang out more. God's good.
I'm here today so you know.
Okay.
All right. Look, the three of us,
we need monopolies. He has us.
He has the ones we do. Yes. So we've
got to do a triple tray. So the spoof,
give him a green and he gives us,
if we give you both the green,
so then you have monopoly. Yeah,
give a yellow. Then you'd get,
why would she listen? Yeah. The game
of monopoly is literally a month.
I got a big heart. Love that.
Now we're all in the game.
Okay. All right. Now I just made
it fun. I love you for that.
We need more people in life.
What is a secret to money or success
that everybody should know to make money?
You have been willing to
be risk of money as well,
and I'm going to add to that and in
terms of not being attached to what money
means to you,
if you disconnect that attachment to it,
what dreams it could create,
then it opens up a lot of possibilities.
I feel like a secret to success is finding
happiness with what you got right now.
So if you're happy now and you get that
thing, and that's like a dessert meeting,
you know, it's like, oh hey man. Yeah,
yeah,
yeah. He and can I pee real
quick? Okay, I'll be right back.
Roll the dice to highest roller,
may dare the others to do anything to get
out of a dare. Pay $125 to the bank. Oh,
that's good. On that dude,
you're going to bathroom. It's,
I'm only roll the dice and whoever
rolls the highest gets to create a deck
for him since he's not
here. Good. All right.
we made an agreement.
The highest role gets to create
a dare for you. What does it do?
The running man for 15 seconds is the
running man the thing where you go just
running, no running man. Running
man is an American thing.
It's like you come in
last place in a marathon.
What does it mean to be successful?
Success for me is uh,
having a roof over your head,
having food on the table
and most importantly having
a family and people that
love you and you loved them.
To me, being successful is
alignment with your vision.
It doesn't have to be monetary or
business wise on your deathbed.
I don't think any one of us in this table
is going to be really like cherishing
the car keys to our bins were like
the keys to our mansion. Yeah,
we agree with that. Yeah. Your success
is defined by the people who love you.
Wow. I like it. Didn't think
you would road so too. Okay.
So I totally lost everything from
everything that you've gotten for 50 days,
so it's pretty bad.
Give him everything you own.
If this is a reflection of how I
run my business and I'm not going
to, Hey, I'm glad I bought that house.
Look who came up with
40 maybe being generous.
Yeah,
let's cash out. It's probably his
counsel. You catch up this chart accounts,
but I'm not going to count shit.
I know I'm not a part of it.
I'm at 61 excuse over 2001
I guess being nice is good.
Yeah. Wow. I helped out the
people who need it all. You
not really too much houses.
Strategizer back. Good heart. That was
great. That was great. This is the prize.
That's insane
conversation.
I think he won because he had to go pee.
I actually really needed some money.
My wife and I are really in
a financial stolen goods.